der Bundesrat bedauert dass die CS nicht
in der Lage war die Schwierigkeiten aus
eigener Kraft zu meistern es ist das
Ende einer Ära
167 Jahre nach ihrer Gründung wird die
Credit Suisse von der UBS geschluckt nur
so konnte die CS vor dem Kollaps bewahrt
werden
wenn sie Milliarden am Boden bezahlen
und Verlust machen
das macht keinen Sinn
für das Debakel
zu schauen ist immer einfach und
irgendwo den Finger hinzulegen hätte die
Firma früher durchgreifen müssen bei der
CS
wer ist Bewilligungen
es ist die letzte Generalversammlung der
CS Route zwei Wochen nach dem klar ist
dass die Bank untergeht
wissen Sie was cas heißt
chronische Skandale haben sie Geld
verloren ja
das ist ein Teil von meinem Alter
dass das
verantwortlich sind
richtig Kappe putzt wird am Ende ging
alles ganz schnell abgezeichnet hat sich
der Untergang der CS allerdings schon
lange Rückblende ins Jahr 2022 die
Credit Suisse wird zur
serienverlustschreiberin die letzten
Illusionen sind zusammengefahren eine
Krise wie die jetzige hat die Bank
jedoch noch nie erlebt allein in der
Schweiz haben Kunden 1,7 Milliarden in
diesem Quartal von der Bank abgezogen
über 10% hat die cs-aktie heute verloren
die Financial Times in London das über
die CS stets bestens informierte
leibblatt der Teppiche Taschen für
Steven Morris ist klar dass Ende der CS
hat sie schon lange abgezeichnet
[Musik]
gab es immer wieder sehr ernste und
peinliches Skandale die die Moral der
Mitarbeitenden und das Vertrauen der
Aufsichtsbehörden in die Fähigkeit der
Bank ihre Kultur zu ändern und sich zu
sanieren schwinden lassen die binäre
verkauften ihre Aktien vor allem aber
verließen die wohlhabenden Kunden die
Bank was wir in den letzten drei Jahren
erlebt haben ist der Höhepunkt eines
Jahrzehnts laxen Verhaltens schlechter
Unternehmenskultur schlechte
Entscheidungen und das Versagen der
aufeinander folgenden Management-Teams
aber auch die Aufsichtsbehörden und das
politische ist Management in der Schweiz
bekamen die Sache nicht in den Griff
Ende Oktober 2022 die CS versucht das
Ruder mit einer neuen Strategie
herumzureißen
was wir heute machen ist nicht einfach
nochmal etwas reorganisieren sondern
wirklich
fundamental die Weichen für die Zukunft
stellen so dass wir eine viel bessere
Balance haben die CS will ihre
Investmentbank halbieren 9000 Stellen
abbauen und das Eigenkapital stärken
der damalige Finanzminister versucht zu
beruhigen
neue Strategie verabschiedet setze die
um für zu einer massiven Kostenreduktion
sie vermindertsrisiko und sie ans fertig
brachte der schwierige Situation Kapital
aufstocken also es geht der Reihe von
guten Maßnahmen
die Strategie war keine radikale Abkehr
von dem was die Credit Suisse schon seit
mehreren Jahren gemacht hatte es war nur
eine ein bisschen tiefgreifendere und
ein bisschen schnellere Methode dies zu
tun die Betonung liegt auf ein bisschen
es war nicht schnell genug sie taten das
richtige indem sie die Investmentbank
verkleinerten und versuchten das Risiko
zu reduzieren aber das Problem war sie
haben nicht sehr viel Geld verdient ich
denke dass neue Management-Team als
Lehmann als Vorsitzender und ulrikaner
Urli das Messer wie er für seine
Fähigkeiten zur Kostensenkung genannt
wird hatten schlechte Karten sie
versuchten ihr Bestes zu geben aber ich
bin mir nicht sicher ob sie jemals
erfolgreich gewesen wäre
damals wird auch bekannt die saudina
Bank wird zur neuaktionärin der Credits
das Kapital wird um 4 Milliarden Franken
erhöht ein bedeutender Teil davon kommt
aus Riad
für Oswald Grübel der bei beiden
Schweizer Großbanken der CS und der UBS
CEO war ein kapitaler Fehler
da sehen sie wie
wenig alle Beteiligten über das
Bankgeschäft wissen wenn Sie eine
kapitaler hören bei wurde Akte bei vier
Franken ist für ein Viertel des
buchwärts gehandelt wird machen und
beinahe Anzahl Aktien bei einer
verdoppeln was denken Sie was dann
passiert das sagt ihnen jeder der nur
das Grundwissen von
Finanzamt sagt in die Akte wird sich
halbieren und in dem Moment wo eine
schlechte Nachricht kommt seine Pleite
fertig wollen dann passiert weil die
Leute gucken alle auf den Aktienkurs er
interessiert nicht dann was ihr Teil
gesagt oder kommuniziert aber das da
muss man kein Chemie sein und das zu
wissen
wie ernst es um die CS steht ist Ende
2022 offenbar auch den Schweizer
Behörden bewusst wie inzwischen bekannt
wurde
die Situation der Credit Suisse gibt
seit mehreren Monaten Anlass zur Sorge
deshalb hat sich der Bundesrat in dieser
Zeit mehrfach über den Zustand der Bank
unterhalten in enger Abstimmung mit der
FINMA und der Schweizer Nationalbank
eine entschiedene Intervention
beispielsweise von der Firma bleibt
allerdings aus dabei gäbe es durchaus
Ermessensspielraum im Bankengesetz heißt
es besteht begründete Besorgnis dass
eine Bank überschuldet ist oder
ernsthafte Liquiditätsprobleme hat dann
kann die Finma Schutzmaßnahmen ein
Sanierungsverfahren oder die Konkurs
liegt wieder anordnen
die CS verneigte allerdings bis kurz vor
ihrem Ende dass es Grund zu einer
solchen Besorgnis gebe
Eimer Brunetti ist Professor für
Wirtschaftspolitik und Finanzstabilität
dass es in der Theorie
Interventionsmöglichkeiten gebe sage
noch wenig zur Praxis natürlich innere
ideale Welt würde immer vorher
intervenieren bevor man den wuchern an
die schon mal alles entscheiden muss
aber stellen Sie mal vor Thema war im
Oktober 22 22
machen auch wenn es an sich völlig
richtig sie waren möglicherweise wenn
das wenn das muss man immer Komponenten
Arbeit brauchen es musste
den Vorwurf bei der CS nicht tätig
geworden zu sein weil sie zurück sagt
der Film mal Direktor
natürlich bei der CS immer wieder müde
Risiko Appetit und nicht so gut die
Risikokultur und darum haben wir das
immer wieder gemacht
und CS hätte ja auch umgesetzt das
Problem ist die sind einfach immer
wieder aufpoppt die verschiedenen
Bereichen
2021 kadermann bei der Firma auch die
Angst vor einem Misserfolg könne eine
Rolle spielen bei Interventionen sagt er
aus Erfahrung
[Musik]
das ist das Schlimmste passiert und die
aufwärtigen musst machen wir sind Chance
und die Chance sind eben nicht immer gut
sie auch immer wieder Öffentlichkeit
Katastrophe das läuft
jetzt noch runterfallen
Probleme ja und dazu kann ich dir die
Baustelle kann ich dir die Straße Graben
macht oder ja bis
die Firma Interventionen haben die CS
offenbar wenig beeindruckt
in Zürich West treffen wir zwei
ehemalige cs-bankerinnen die hier seit
drei Jahren ihre eigene Firma führen
[Musik]
Kultur hat für meine sehr kurzfristigs
handle toleriert wenn nicht unterstützt
und zum anderen sind kritische Stimmen
Fragezeichen
bis 2019 bei der CS in leitender
Position im Bereich der Derivate der
voranalysten und der Anlage Spezialisten
für Schweizer Kunden
Luba König von 2006 bis 2014 bei der CS
im Bereich der Derivate und später
zuständig für Anlage und kreditlösungen
der größten Kunden Ost Europas
und etwas sehr sehr wichtig es ist der
Bankenindustrie wie es momentan des
tagesgeräusch scheint die Seele abhanden
gekommen zu sein wenn man sich nur auf
der Kompensation bezieht und sagt okay
klar stellen wir sicher dass man
genügend Geld bekommt dann bleiben schon
die Leute man kauft die Leute aber kauft
man wirklich oder sichert man wirklich
ihr Engagement sehen sie wirklich
motiviert fühlen sie sich wohl die
Kultur das sind alles Unternehmens und
das hier unglaublich das sind wirklich
die wichtigsten Ressourcen warum hat
denn das Management warum man all die
Kontrolle versaut bitte credit Swiss
ich glaube das führte im Endeffekt auf
Kultur zurück das das Kultur akzeptiert
worden ist wo wo viele Entscheidungen wo
treffen worden sind hat hauptsächlich
Wissen Situationen wie Sie individuell
kurzfristige gewinnen was das erwünscht
sehe ich dass das toleriert worden ist
und Medi die mittelfristig oder
längerfristige Interessen von der Bank
sind und ich denke das ist das ist ja im
Endeffekt kein Problem
heute geben die beiden ihr Wissen an der
Uni Zürich weiter ihr Publikum Banking
und finance Studierende ihnen erzählen
sie von der investitionsplattform die
sie betreiben die es nicht
professionellen Anlegern ermöglichen
soll ihr Geld zu investieren
uns liegt sehr am Herzen dass wir
Finanzinformationen einfach zugänglich
zur Verfügung gestellt werden und auch
sehr leicht und intuitiv verständlich
das Ende der CS beschäftigt auch die
Studierenden können sie liebt
natürlich
und natürlich müssen die Eltern jetzt
nicht genau wie es weiter geht das
vorangebote CS sind
und ich kann der Park Kollege wo er
daheim nicht ganz sicher sind
Nachrichten es ist sehr viel umgegangen
und ich kann halt auch paar Leute wo das
auch direkt betreffen
hätte können irgendwie besetzt werden
und ich hoffe mal dass sie sich
irgendwie wieder alles sicher hier
reguliert
sehr viel von der Bank hatte profitieren
emotionelle Momente die ganze Familie
ja die Betroffenheit
und natürlich auch sehr viel Wut das
muss man auch sagen also viele sind auch
wirklich richtig wütend das ist so weit
gekommen ist
[Musik]
die Wurzeln der Credit Suisse reichen
zurück bis ins Jahr 1856
damals entstand die schweizerische
Kreditanstalt
mitgegründet vom großen Politiker
Wirtschaftsführer und
eisenbahnunternehmer Alfred Escher
Escher brauchte eine eigene Bank um
seine ehrgeizigen eisenbahnpläne zu
finanzieren
der Bau des Gotthardtunnels ohne Escher
und seine Hausbank undenkbar
[Musik]
Wirtschaftshistoriker Tobias Straumann
sagt das Spiel mit riesigen habe schon
immer zum Wesen der CS gehört
die große Geschäft gemacht hätte der
internationale geschafft und vor allem
Finanzierung das ist extrem
anspruchsvoll sie und es ist offen und
arbeitgegangen und
die damalige
Stunde also das gehört auch zu der DNA
von sich immer der Bank
ist als die Kreditanstalt die Volksbank
schluckt entsteht die CS wie wir sie
heute kennen Bilder aus dem Jahr 1993
der starke Mann ist damals
Verwaltungsratspräsident Rainer eh gut
er hat große Pläne mit der Bank mehr ist
Schweiz
und geschafft haben
auf kritischer Nachfragen reagiert der
frühere wallstreet-banker gereizt
mit den Bilanzsummen wächst auch das Ego
der CS Banker
bescheidener Superstar solche
Schlagzeilen lassen sich cscarder wie
Lukas Mühlemann dagegen gerne gefallen
die Banker als moderne Helden zwar
fürstlich entlöhnt aber wegen ihrer
Kompetenz jeden Franken wert
dieses Bild bekommt spätestens beim
rounding 2001 tiefe Risse im
Verwaltungsrat saßen nämlich auch CS
Bank
[Musik]
der Verwaltungsratspräsident wechselt in
der Folge bei der CS die Haltung dagegen
nicht
2003 übernimmt Walter kielholz das Ruder
unter ihm wird der deutsche Oswald
Grübel CEO bei den Gehältern geht es nun
steilaufwärts die Geschäftsleitung
kassiert im Durchschnitt 20 Millionen
pro Person und Jahr
bittet nicht sagen jetzt sehe ich das es
ist
ja natürlich war es vielleicht zu viel
dort aber wenn Sie mich fragen was sie
vielleicht interessiert oder wo sie nah
drauf hinaus hat habe ich ein schlechtes
Gewissen nein was ist gerechter wenn wir
damit anfangen es gibt die ganze Welt
ist ungerecht
fertig wir können Sie kein schlechtes
Gewissen einrichten tut mir leid
auf Oswald
2007 der Amerikaner Brady Düren der bis
dahin die Investmentbank leitete
Bonanza jetzt richtig los
ja dass ich für mich typisch Beispiel
das ist eine wo aus Investmentbanking
kommt und kann
die
blauen und Mittag Märkte interessiert
Schweiz überhaupt nicht gefällt sich für
Schweizer Bank wo Vermögensverwaltung
das komische Personalpolitik welche Zug
geht es doch nicht andere Leute das
besser könnte
ST antritt überhitzt sich der
amerikanische Immobilienmarkt
die Hypothekarzinsen steigen
die Hausbesitzer können sie nicht mehr
bezahlen und müssen ausziehen
damit verlieren nicht nur die Häuser
massiv an Wert sondern auch Hypotheken
Wertpapiere
sogenannte subprime Papiere
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im Jahr darauf 2018 geht niemand
Brothers eine amerikanische Bank pleite
der Auftakt des großen Zusammenbruchs
nach der Immobilienblase platzt jetzt
auch noch die Kreditblase Kurssturz
[Musik]
die UBS steht nun am Abgrund denn sie
hat eine aggressive Expansionsstrategie
in den USA verfolgt sie ist sehr
exponiert am amerikanischen Immobilien
und Derivate Markt
sie schreibt Verluste in Milliardenhöhe
der Schweizer Staat muss die UBS retten
denn die UBS ist to big to fail zu groß
um untergehen zu können unsere
Engagement
für den finanzkreislauf also unter den
Banken auch wir verstehen es als
Engagement also Unterstützung für die
KMU
in der Schweiz die intensiven
bankenverkehr haben wir verstehen nicht
als Engagement für die Wirtschaft das
Bund und Nationalbank der UBS mit 68
Milliarden Franken unter die Arme
greifen müssen lässt die Emotionen
hochgehen
hier haben die wespenbäcker die
Weltwirtschaft naido an den Abgrund
gebracht
der Staat soll künftig nicht mehr
einspringen müssen bei einer solchen
Krise dafür sollte die Politik sorgen
[Applaus]
to big to fail zu Big zu back to face
zu groß zum untergehen
wie rettet man eine Bank ohne Steuergeld
eine Expertenkommission debattiert zwei
Jahre lang
unter der Leitung des finanzdepartements
die Zusammenarbeit in der aus vertreten
von Behörden der Wissenschaft der
Realwirtschaft und dem Finanzsektor
zusammengesetzten Kommission war
intensiv
wir haben jetzt ein Paket geschnürt ein
Paket von dem wir auch überzeugt sind
dass es maßgeblich zur Begrenzung der
tubice Risiken beitragen wird die
Kommission fordert Großbanken müssen
mehr Eigenkapital und Liquidität halten
und
im Notfall müsste eine Bank aufgespaltet
werden können die Tochtergesellschaften
im Ausland gingen Konkurs der Schweizer
Teil der Bank aber würde überleben und
weiter funktionieren
Ziel der Maßnahmen gegen dieses tubic to
fail muss es daher sein den Steuerzahler
aus dieser ungewollten Haftung zu
entlassen
Rolf
Mitglied der Expertenkommission damals
2010 ein Schwergewicht der Wirtschaft
als ehemaliger Verwaltungsratspräsident
von Lonza und Holz im
die aufspaltige er hat davon
dass in Anerkennung vor verflachtigen wo
innerhalb von Organisationen bestehen
die aufspaltig gar nicht so einfach denn
zu machen ist im Einzelfall das ist
quantworte aber
vom schweizerischen Kerngeschäft mit den
entscheidenden Elementen
am Land bedeutend sind total x verkehrt
Spar kurz Sport geschafft
etc das ist eigentlich unbestritten
im Ständerat herrschte heute Einigkeit
wie selten ohne Gegenstimme wurde die
Vorlage gut geheißen 36 zu null bei zwei
Enthaltungen trotz langer Diskussion
stehen am Schluss alle politischen Lager
hinter den neuen Regeln wir wollen
Gewehr haben dass eine Bank eben auch
Konkurs gehen kann
das Ende der Credit Suisse muss zwei
Banken wird ein Bank
eine Traditionsbank stirbt ein neuer
Gigant entsteht
basierend auf den Notverordnung des
Bundesrats können Credit Suisse und UBS
ein
Liquiditätshilfe Darlehen in der Höhe
von insgesamt bis zu 100 Milliarden
Franken beziehen
zusätzlich dazu und passieren auf den
notfallordnung des Bundesrats kann die
Nationalbank der Credit Suisse ein mit
einer ausfallgarantie des Bundes
gesichertes Liquiditätshilfe Darlehen in
der Höhe von bis zu 100 Milliarden
Franken gewähren
Notrecht wieder milliardenschwere
Garantien vom Steuerzahler was ist mit
dem two big to fail Plan warum wurde er
nicht angewendet ja warum hat man jetzt
nicht einfach die Gruppe Konkurs gehen
lassen und hat der Schweiz Geschäft
weitergeführt das ist bei einer
systemrelevanten Bank in dieser Größe
noch nie passiert oder die Verbindung
zwischen der UBS der kreditsuisse
natürlich eigen auch mit den anderen
Banken und eben auch auf den
internationalen Finanzmärkten das hätte
also ich würde sagen mit ziemlicher
Sicherheit eine Finanzkrise ausgelöst 15
Jahre wirklich vernünftig geschaffen
genau
also es war nie eine Option und das
waren Traum und dann auch hätte er sein
Signal an den Rest der Welt gesendet wo
man sich gesagt hat moment mal die
Schweiz in dem Moment wo schwierig wird
nimmt sich das Filetstück eben das
Schweizer Geschäft Business oder
Kundengeschäft das behält sie und das
Ausland darf sich mit dem Rest
rumschlagen mit dem schwierigeren
Problemen wir wären erledigt und äh als
Land als Finanzplatz einmal Brunetti
gilt als Vater der tubito-fell
Gesetzgebung war seine Arbeit umsonst
zum Schluss kommt noch der Analyse vor
dem Fall
dass man tatsächlich immer müsst ihr
stattlich so ganz hilfs gehen
denn bin ich Automatik denn hängt den
Handballen letzte Konsequenzen
Staatsgarantie und das ist inakzeptabel
also wenn die Schätze ist das
ursprüngliche zept wo man nicht in der
Schweiz umgesetzt haben in plausible
Krise nicht funktionieren dann muss man
zu anderen Ausnahme
ja sie sagen im Nachhinein ist jede
Generation naiv nehme
immer wieder dazu wir haben das gehört
nicht vorsehen
wahrscheinlich weil niemand bei der
Beratung dabei war der das Geschäft
kennt aber sie hat ja
dabei
waren drei Bänker in der
Expertenkommission der Rest war
Profession und
sonstige Leute aus der wirtschaften
außerdem stand ich täglich im Austausch
mit Kollegen im Ausland insbesondere
Kolleginnen
aus den USA und auch Jeremy Hand in UK
beide Finanzplätze sind natürlich
wichtig und auch auf diesen
Finanzplätzen UK und USA spielt die
Credit Suisse eine wichtige Rolle
als sich das Problem zuspitzte entstand
immenser internationaler Druck es sah so
aus als ob die Credit Suisse eine
schwere Vertrauenskrise erleiden könnte
infolgedessen begannen Leute hier im
Vereinigten Königreich aber auch in
Frankreich und bei der US-Notenbank
starten Druck auf die Schweizer
auszuüben wie ein Insider beschrieb
sie haben die Schweizer in den Arsch
getreten eine sehr umgangssprachliche
Art und zu sagen dass sie die Schweizer
trinken die Krise in den Griff zu
bekommen
Russland verlangt hat dass mir zu einer
rasche klar kommunizierbare
gut darstellbare Lösungen vielleicht
hat mir garantieren alles mehr zahle was
es braucht wir sagen
möglichen minimal oder genügend
beruhigen vor der Weltmarkt geführt hat
was immer nötig ist das zentrale
Stichwort
hinter dem Zürcher Paradeplatz treffen
wir den Mann der bei der
Finanzmarktaufsicht für den Bereich true
big to fail verantwortlich war Reto
Schildknecht er sagt die Arbeiten für
die Aufspaltung einer Bank sei nicht
abgeschlossen
die ganze liquiditätskonzept im Konkurs
die sind offen oder also dass ich eine
für das würde ich sagen dass ich
eigentlich
beim Konkurs der weltweit tätigen
cs-bank mit Sitz in der Schweiz hätten
vor allem die Bankkunden der
Zweigniederlassungen im Ausland Verluste
erlitten vor allem in New York Singapur
und Hongkong während ihrer Einlagen
nicht durch die Banken gedeckt gewesen
hätte wohl der Bund einspringen müssen
mit dem sogenannten public liquidity
bugstop einem Schutzschirm garantiert
von den Schweizer steuerzahlenden ein
Gesetz dafür gibt es aber noch nicht der
Public weder die Bergstock das ist quasi
das letzte Sicherheitsnetz wenn wenn
quasi Bank
kassicherheiten
denn und der Länder auf der Last last
resort
aber ich springen Sie also
Milliarden garantiert für die Gläubigen
Punkt
sieht der UBS retik versprochen keine
Hilfe mehr vom Staat da hat man doch am
volksandet
also die Kommunikation ist also mein
Geschirr kolusativ
sagen
noch mindere persönliche Meinung hat
doch proaktiven können kommunizieren und
tätowiert
es geht noch Risiken und die Risiken
adressiert werden oder man muss aber
auch sagen dass dieser wäre auch in
anderen Szenarien zum Tragen gekommen
also wenn man beispielsweise eine
Verstaatlichung der Bank angestrebt
hätte also wenn der der Bund die Bank
übernommen hätte ein Tipp hier auch dann
hätte es das auch gebraucht oder auch
bei einer Sanierung hätte es das
gebraucht also dieser PLB diese
vorübergehende zur Verfügung Stellung
der Liquidität wäre eigentlich in allen
Szenarien die wir auf dem Radar hatten
zu Anwendung gekommen
muss mit einer Fußgänger
relevantenfall haben Garantie
die Bilder erinnern an 2008 wieder wird
auf dem Paradeplatz demonstriert wieder
wegen der staatsrettung einer Großbank
diesmal jene der CS dass die CS nun
gerettet werden musste hat vermutlich
viel damit zu tun dass sie es 2018
bei der CS führte die globale
Finanzkrise allerdings nicht zu einem
Umdenken trotz Riesenverlust wurden 2
Milliarden Boni ausbezahlt für 2018
ab 2007 CEO ist die Verkörperung dieser
Maßlosigkeit
2009 bezieht er ein Gehalt von 20
Millionen plus eine Bonus von 70
Millionen
mit einer gesamtentlöhnung von 90
Millionen Franken ist sogar nun der
bestbezahlte Bankmanager Europas
diese Lohn Exzesse wollte Thomas minder
mit seiner Abzocker-Initiative stoppen
die Aktionäre sollten die Gehälter an
den Generalversammlungen nach unten
korrigieren können
aber irgendetwas ist schief gelaufen
[Musik]
denn die Aktionäre sind nach der Annahme
seiner Initiative nicht eingeschritten
bei der CS
also der Aktion
übrigens auch institutionelle
Risiko Evaluation sondern
auch mit verantwortlich oder passiert
ist ist das
ausgeht ist
guten Tag natürlich
bei den letzten 10 Jahren Initiative vor
zehn Jahren 2017
es hat bitte ein und andere Unternehmen
wirklich für gemäß
70 Millionen es ist irgendwas 11 12 13
Millionen aber auch noch viel ich war
auch noch abzockreich ist es wenigstens
doppelter
die Banken müssten besser beaufsichtigt
werden nicht nur von den Aktionären
sondern von einer starken Behörde hieß
es nach der Krise 2008
die eidgenössische Bankenkommission kurz
EBK sei mit den Risiken des
Finanzplatzes überfordert
darum wird die Finanzmarktaufsicht kurz
Finma gegründet sie soll fortan alle
Bereiche des Finanzwesens insbesondere
auch Banken beaufsichtigen und
kontrollieren
Peter V Kunz ist der Ansicht dass mit
der FINMA eine Behörde geschaffen wurde
die im Grunde zahnlos ist
zehnmal Schütt sehr schwach ausgestaltet
ausländische
Aufsichtsbehörden
die Kompetenz
offensichtlich CS relativ unwirsch
reagiert hat offen für die
bis aber jetzt hat es gerade die letzte
Tag
eigentlich nicht super umgesetzt ja die
setzt nicht um wenn sie weiß es nicht
passieren und viel mache ich gar nicht
so mit Duka dass die Firma kritisiert
wird ist nicht neu bisher allerdings
nicht etwa weil sie zu zahm wäre im
Gegenteil den Bankern war sie zu mächtig
ja wir fordern dass die immer das tut
wofür sie vorgesehen ist Hinweis die
Finanzmarktaufsicht und nicht die
Finanzmarkt Regulierung
und die finden mehr soll nur dort
regulieren wo dies mit Blick auf die
aufsichtszwecke auch wirklich und
absolut notwendig ist und wenn sie das
nicht tut dann überschreitet sie ihre
Kompetenz den einen zu mächtig den
anderen zu zahm in diesem Spannungsfeld
bewegt sich die Firma
sie müssen verstehen es gibt immer zwei
Seiten natürlich will niemand mehr
reguliert werden weil es eben in der
Geschäftstätigkeit einschränkt
möglichst wenig Aufsicht das war auch
der cs-recht
2011 bekommt sie einen neuen
Verwaltungsratspräsidenten Urs Rohner
einen
juristenreiches Investmentbanking
ungestört betreiben
beide Großbanken haben ab sofort deine
unterschiedliche Strategie die UBS hat
eigentlich hier Investmentbank
degradiert zum Wurmfortsatz der
Vermögensverwaltung kann ich jetzt mal
sagen und sie sagen weiterhin
Investmentbank ist eine Säule in unserem
Geschäft bleibt so ähm zur Strategie der
UBS kann und will ich mich nicht im
Einzelnen äußern was uns betrifft wir
sind überzeugt davon dass unsere
Strategie für unsere für unsere Bank die
Richtige ist wenn wir den Geschäften
drin sind die nachhaltige ertragswirksam
und profitabel betrieben werden können
und auch Geschäfte die eben in Märkten
besonders sich stark herausstellen
werden die in den nächsten Jahren stark
wachsen werden unter uns Rona produziert
die CS zahlreiches Skandale Ihre noch
offenen Rechtsfälle übernimmt nun die
obs
der Fall Mosambik zwischen 2013 und 2016
vergab die CS in Mosambik Kredite für
den Aufbau einer fischfangflotte und für
Schnellboote für die Küstenwache die CS
soll in Korruption und
Schmiergeldzahlungen verwickelt sein
muss musste staatsbankrot anmelden im
Oktober 2023 steht ein Prozess vor dem
englischen heikot an es könnte zu einer
milliardenzahlung an die Kläger kommen
der Fall FIFA
2015 hat die US-Justiz Anklage erhoben
gegen Personen und Organisationen im
Umfeld der FIFA im Zuge dieser
Ermittlungen erhielt auch die CS
Anfragen der US-Justiz unter anderem
geht es um Geldwäsche
der Verwaltungsrat der CS bekommt die
Probleme nicht in den Griff kassiert
aber fleißig ab nach Brady dugen der den
all glatten Banker geradezu perfekt
verkörpert übernimmt jetzt seine
schillernde Persönlichkeit mit Charme
und Emotionen wie Sie sehen mein
geschätzten Damen und Herren mein
Deutsch ist etwas lustig geworden
2015 wird die Jandia
du kannst Nachfolger kommt von einer
englischen Versicherung und soll die CS
strategisch neu ausrichten
weg vom risikoreichen Investmentbanking
hat den 8 Jahren 160 Millionen Franken
verdient der Aktienkurs fiel derweil um
64%
der Wechsel von dugen zu tiamm soll auch
ein image-mäßiger Neuanfang sein endlich
raus aus den negativschlagteile
offenbar erfolgreich
Firma Kultur extrem Angriffen
gehen die Skandale weiter
Anfang 2020 kann er den Medien einen
satten Gewinn von über 3 Milliarden
präsentieren
gleichzeitig tritt er als CEO zurück
gestolpert ist er über ihn
[Musik]
Chef der internationalen
Vermögensverwaltung der CS wurde nach
seinem Abgang zur Konkurrentin UBS von
Privatdetektiven überwacht
aus meiner Sicht des ganzen
Verwaltungsrates war dieser
auftragsüberwachung falsch und
unangemessen auch wenn sie subjektiv zum
Schutz der Interessen der Gesellschaft
angeordnet wurde
nicht verhältnismäßig und sie spricht
nicht den Kriterien und Maßstäben die
Gesellschaft an unsere Arbeit legen
später kommt heraus es wird noch andere
Mitarbeiter überwacht
der Druck wird zu groß
Anfang 2020 gehen in seinen fünf Jahren
bei der Credit Suisse kassierte er
insgesamt 90 Millionen Franken
der Aktienkurs fiel in seiner Amtszeit
um 55%
. die Skandale gehen derweil weiter bei
der CS und werden nach der Übernahme
durch die UBS nun zu deren Problem weil
das teuer werden kann hat der Bundesrat
vorgesaugt
konkret hat der Bundesrat eine Garantie
im Umfang von 9 Milliarden Franken
gesprochen um allfällige Risiken der UBS
zu reduzieren was genau damit gemeint
ist ist unklar klar ist indes es gibt
auch noch den Fall Steuerstreit USA
2014 musste sich die damalige cs-spitze
vor dem US-Senat wegen Beihilfe zur
Steuerhinterziehung von US-Bürgern
verantworten der damalige CEO Brady Doug
und schwor das ist nie mehr vorkäme
es gab Mitarbeiter die wissenschaftlich
gegen US-Recht verstießen obwohl ich
sehr bestürzt bin über ihr Fehlverhalten
stellt sich das Management der
Vergangenheit und übernimmt die
Verantwortung
die CS zahlte eine Busse von 2,6
Milliarden Dollar
weil sie unterschrieb nie mehr ein
solches Verhalten an den Tag zu legen
gab es eine Ermäßigung von 1,3
Milliarden Dollar diese Geschichte
könnte die cs- und mit ihr die UBS nun
einholen denn gemäß eine Bericht des
US-Senats habe die Bank nicht damit
aufgehört us-steuerpflichtigen beim
hinterziehen von Steuern zu helfen
breaking news Ende März 2023 auf dem
US-Sender CNBC
das Finanzkomitee des Senats
veröffentlicht zur Stunde einen neuen
Bericht in dem die Anschuldigungen von
Informanten gegen die Kredit Suisse
detailliert aufgeführt sind im Bericht
wird behauptet dass die CS
amerikanischen Kunden dabei geholfen hat
Hunderte von Millionen Dollar vor dem
Finanzamt zu verstecken obwohl sie sich
vor zehn Jahren zur Zusammenarbeit mit
den US-Steuerbehörden verpflichtet hatte
geleitet wurde die zweijährige
Untersuchung von Senator Ron Weiden
die Ermittlungen dauern noch an gerade
in den letzten Tagen wurde festgestellt
dass noch mehr Geld unterschlagen wurde
es gibt hier einige sehr wichtige Fragen
die CS schreibt
die Credit Suisse toleriert keine
Steuerhinterziehung der Bericht
beschreibt im Wesentlichen Altlasten
einige davon reichen bis zu zehn Jahre
zurück die Bank hat seit ihr umfassende
Maßnahmen eingeführt um Personen zu
identifizieren welche versuchen
Vermögenswerte zu verbergen
Basis des Reports sind Aussagen von
Whistleblowern ehemalige CS Banker ihr
Anwalt ist Jeff Leimen die Informationen
seiner Klienten haben dazu geführt dass
im Lauf der Untersuchung zahlreiche
nicht deklarierte cs-konten von
us-steuerpflichtigen zum Vorschein kamen
seine Klienten haben ein finanzielles
Interesse denn wenn die CS dank ihnen
erneut gebüst wird bekommen sie einen
Anteil
sie haben soeben vor dem Finanzkomitee
des Senats zugegeben dass sie geholfen
haben nach 2014 mehr als 700 Millionen
Dollar zu verstecken das ist ein Verstoß
gegen ihr Versprechen deshalb stecken
sie heute in Schwierigkeiten
vor seiner Tätigkeit als Anwalt war Jeff
Leimen ein Hoch dekorierter
us-staatsanwalt beim obs Fall 2008 war
er einer der führenden Staatsanwälte
zum Abschied schenkten ihm die Kollegen
eine Erinnerung die UBS in den Fängen
der US-Justiz
manches hat sich geändert manches aber
nicht das Verhaltensmuster der Credits
wie es heute ist noch beleidigender als
das was die UBS damals getan hat die CS
hat ihre Lektion nicht gelernt
ob die US-Justiz aktiv werden wird oder
nicht lässt sich heute nicht sagen
ungemütlich ist die Situation für CS und
UBS auf jeden Fall
wie hoch könnten Busen ausfallen
die Frage wie viel die Kredit suis
letztlich zahlen muss ist die eine
Milliarde Dollar Frage
wie hoch könnte diese Zahl sein ich
denke die Untergrenze liegt bei 1,3
Milliarden und die Obergrenze
wahrscheinlich bei drei vier oder fünf
Milliarden Dollar wer weiß das
Schoner verabschiedet sich im april 2021
wegen Corona in einer virtuellen GV zwar
mit einem Gewinn von über 3 Milliarden
aber auch mit weiteren Skandalen die
hochbar geworden sind
wir haben unsere Kundinnen und Kunden
aber auch unsere Aktionärinnen und
Aktionäre enttäuscht und dies leider
nicht zum ersten Mal
entschuldige ich mich der Aktienkurs ist
unter Rohner um über 70% gefallen
kassiert hatte derweil über 50 Millionen
Franken
[Musik]
Urs Rona hat heute ein Büro in Zürcher
Seefeld über einen Sprecher lässt er den
Medien ausrichten er zahle nichts von
seinem Lohn zurück
52 Millionen nicht
Orio ein Portugiese übernimmt von ozona
meine Damen und Herren Monsieur Signal
zwei weitere Skandale okay goss und
greencill
der Fall okay goss beim Zusammenbruch
von Bill Horns Hedgefonds 2021 erlitt
die CS einen Verlust in Milliardenhöhe
im dezember 2022 einigte sich die Bank
mit Klägern die endgültige gerichtliche
Genehmigung steht noch aus
zivilrechtliche Klagen sind hängig und
weitere Rechtsstreitigkeiten könnten
drohen
der Fall greensill im Frühling 2021
brach der Lieferketten von greensill
zusammen die Credit Suisse musste vier
Fonds von greensill capital einfrieren
in die cs-konten 10 Milliarden Dollar
investiert hatten sie will klagen gegen
die Bank sind hängig weitere könnten
folgen
wo waren die Aufseher was war der
Verwaltungsrat was Wasser denn
Verwaltungsrat dazu bewogen weil er muss
die Boni genehmigen er zahlt die Boni
die Zahlen nicht die Geschäftsleitung
sich selbst das so zu handhaben
ich weiß es nicht was die gedacht haben
die CS taumelt nun ihrem Ende entgegen
im Jahr 2022 schreibt sie nur noch
Verluste das Vertrauen in die Bank ist
verloren ihr Schicksal damit besiegelt
es fließt immer mehr Geld ab bis der
Bund im März 2023 die Notbremse zieht
die UBS schluckt die CS und sie bekommt
einen neuen Chef
[Musik]
Rückkehr der Banken
ist er der Richtige für den Job
der neue ist der alte
schon 2011 hat es Sergio armotti das
Steuer der UBS übernommen nach Oswald
Grübel ich habe
kriegt fünfmal mehr lohnen und
schätze ich ins gemachte Bett sozusagen
was wollen sie da ändern
2013 heftige Kritik an Ermotti wegen
hoher Löhne und Boni ich hoffe ich
bekomme weil ich sicher ich hoffe ich
bekomme keine Tomaten
2,5 Millionen Franken trotz staatlicher
Garantien erhält er einen Bonus Höhe
unbekannt klar ist die UBS ist jetzt so
groß dass sie viel zu groß ist um noch
fallen zu können
ess ich einfach nicht gratis wenn man
internationalen Finanzplatz ist es tut
mir leid so schnell mir einfach
Strategien
und wo und was genau trifft aber das ist
wiederholt das ist eigentlich klar
gefühlt mit 259 Milliarden bitte
billiona also irgendeinisch ruinieren